[Music]
[Applause]
Dan Le batard the popular host of The
Dan Le batard show with Stu gotz and uh
co-founder of Meadowlark media says that
I never reach out when there's anything
positive to say about the Dolphins it's
usually something negative well now it's
time Dan Le batard joining us Dan
congratulations
uh got a clown outfit on it's not a
clown of respect the brand please it's
not just the clown outfit I
I am it's a distinct look I'm I am the
Mad Hatter I am sure as soon as this uh
this uh arrives on people's doorstep
they will call me the Mad fatter
yeah yeah I'm just doing this
preemptively but I've lost a contest we
do when we lose games around here we
pick from a bucket the Kentucky Fried
Chicken bucket of death we we reach in
there and and then when you lose a game
like I do with the San Francisco 49ers
or the Steelers or I'm watching just
this just such bad football and I also
lose and then I have to do the costume
as a punishment so yes that's why I'm
dressed this way okay well
congratulations on the Dolphins they're
playing well and uh I thought of you
that the Dolphins undefeated and you say
that I rarely reach out to talk about
positive things and here it is well I
appreciate you congratulating me as if I
were you know in that heat of the swamp
that was killing those people on Sunday
helping them to Victory backpedaling the
entire game because Josh Allen was
riding around on a horse throwing the
dropping back 73 times how much do you
think that impacts Dan games in
September in Miami
there were three players on the bills
who ran off the sidelines like a stunt
man on fire what do you mean how does it
affect the bills it's climate change is
swamping they had Stefan Diggs was
crawling around on his knees you can't
drop back them I can't believe that it
worked Dan do you realize how rare it is
to watch a football game and be like the
strategy is going to be well the bills
are just going to punch themselves out
they don't realize how hot it is out
there they're in a swamp they haven't
played here all year they're coming from
Buffalo and look on the last fourth down
throw Josh Allen doesn't have the arm
Fork because they actually punch
themselves out
have you had a Ken Dorsey meltdown
have have I ever gotten that mad yeah
yeah a cup only on well not like that I
will I have on two or three occasions
banged on something or thrown something
in Anger why
because I was angry
that's the nature of anchor it's the
very nature of rage and I understand
that some people can bottle it and be
great but the nature I didn't know if
there was a reason for your anger that's
what I was getting at why are you
contentious with me are you combative
why well because look Dan we're fighting
for the look this is what's happening
okay you and me are competing in this
space with these these goddamn young
people and you look at how you age with
Grace Look At You Look At You surrounded
by your toys at the height of the
profession and you're the man a
professor yes and look at me Dan look at
me between your two dollars
all right man what happened look at what
I have to do for the dollars dead I have
to dance for the dollars
look at me yeah I know I feel bad for
you like is everything okay
well generally yes but these are the
Tears of a Clown you're going to open up
my soul now here's the thing Dan about
this damn team okay for 20 years it's
been garbage it's been just an
unrelenting River of diarrhea okay
they've trampled whatever was left of my
fandom as I became an objective
journalist when my father handed me down
this team that made me love sports on
Once Upon a Time and had Mourinho and
for three damn decades was the
witnessing winning his franchise in
sports and I have to watch 20 years of
them ruining yeah three games and I'm
dressed like a clown celebrating that
Robert Griffin says that the Dolphins
are the number one team in America in
week three a clown just be careful with
the language here you know I'm sorry
forgive me be professional be
professional you're doing it's just it's
dirt look not all of us can be as
graceful some of us have to descend into
the sewer to get our clicks down don't
act like Ken Dorsey here just let's be
professionals you know what you're
totally right I'm sorry but forgive me
are you all in on tour
Dan this is why you're the great
journalist that you are
I've not given this public opinion
anywhere on my show for three years I've
been afraid of two or not
this group of people this rabid fan base
around they're unreasonable I've never
seen anything like it covering Sports in
South Florida not LeBron anything
this guy needs to be winner hero savior
we need this in Miami
and so I've sat out that you can't
analyze this guy when last year the
blocking was the worst in the history of
recorded measurement on these things for
this guy and then in this last game they
kept him clean three of their offensive
linemen no pressure the game's changing
nerd ball can protect the quarterback
Garoppolo got a throw away and you're
telling me the Dolphins have a guy with
Speedy receivers who can maybe be
something better than Garoppolo I prefer
to have Herbert or Josh Allen or Patrick
Mahomes or one of these guys that keeps
return you know changing the position
because we've watched Rogers and Brady
now these other guys are like holy I
can't believe how athletic these guys
are I can't believe well Lamar Jackson
did to the dolphin secondary I uh I'm
all in on the idea of Tua I want him to
be a winner because they can mask all
the things that Josh Allen has in arm
strength that maybe he doesn't because
the throw he made to Waddle on Third and
22. I haven't seen many people like who
can make that throw that's a very
difficult throw for anybody to make
well we'll waddle and Tyree kill
Force the Dolphins to give Tua a massive
contract I mean no I'm not doing that
yet nope not getting to the finances yet
no sir I'm going to dress like a clown
and dance before we get to no no no it's
not going to be no but Dan that's what's
changing at the position right they've
all realized you have to have value at
quarterback like we can we can get look
hey I can get Cooper rush I can go 21
for 31 and maybe I can you know what
it's not just getting a good quarterback
can I get one that represents value or
do I have to pay yeah one of the monster
contracts and then I can't pay anyone
else in Burrows getting sacked all over
the place because burrow got all the
money it's not just getting a good
quarterback you got to get one at Value
and that's why that's why yes I'm in on
tour because I believe they'll do that
this organization will now run itself
financially well enough to know whether
they made him something special because
you saw a difference between him and
Bridge Bridgewater
and they still argue about this in New
England was it Belichick or Brady who
made whom special and they'll I I would
like a management team that I can trust
to make the measurement on his value
correctly
uh I'll leave you with this clown uh if
Aaron judge hit 62 home runs
Hoosiers single season home run champ of
all time
if if he hits 62 home runs oh I'm still
doing it with bonds though like are we
still adding like we're trying to do
retroactively where we punish the
medicine guys like no the for for their
time the best player I ever saw was
Barry Bonds and I don't need you to
clean that up for me with some of the
mythologies about how competitive people
might cheat in the margins because
they're super competitive about being
competitive like Barry Bonds forever for
me is the best baseball player I ever
saw
so no problem with anything that he did
in the second half of his career uh well
it's not that I don't have a problem
with it it's that I lost my hall of fame
vote because we were arguing the merits
about whether these guys would go
through the pharmacy to be competitive
when Maguire and Sosa stole the sport
from bonds when they were cheating and
so he started cheating too and he was
better than them when he wasn't cheating
he was better than them when he was
cheating he was better than anybody I've
ever seen Aaron judge included well it's
like you know with Lance Armstrong
everybody cheated in the Tour de France
he was just better at all of those who
cheated
uh but this happened to me I think I've
told you this story where I was at uh at
ESPN I think I got in trouble because uh
PTI I was uh
I I was on during the stuff with bonds
and Lance Armstrong and I was saying
well I don't understand why it's so
different where bonds has all this
circumstantial evidence and we're
totally comfortable burying him for
being a cheater and Lance Armstrong has
just as much circumstantial evidence and
a little more proof and he's hosting the
ESPYs for us this week and I'm I and I
got in trouble like I didn't I never
understood that they both all of those
people were cheating a lot when they
were cheating trying to beat each other
at being the best because competitive
people are going to be
competitive it's funny to me that we
don't ask any questions now of pool
Holtz and Brady and and any of these
guys or or women in their 40s you know
where it's like how how have we cheated
science so much that these people
actually have perfected how to age with
Grace uh in sports in a way I wish we
all could
uh you haven't questioned my abilities
at my age yeah no you're cheating HGH
all over you every morning you sleep in
some hyperbaric chamber where they like
give you good television fumes and keep
you the game show perfect that you are
as I continue look at me slumming and
cursing on your reputable program with
the last of my clown act I'm embarrassed
for myself right now he's the Mad fatter
he is Dan Le batard the host of The Dan
Le batard show with stugots it's great
to talk to you Dan love you buddy thank
you man sorry for the language that's
okay that's okay all right talk to the
FCC I'm a cursing clown you are you're a
clown I'm a cursing clown you're a clown
all of a sudden stugots is the reputable
guy
let's check in with uh our reputable
member Stu guns